confirming sane people's worst fears
Donald Trump has selected Scott Pruitt
to lead the Environmental Protection
Agency Scott Pruett is a total crony of
the fossil fuel industry this is a major
signal that Donald Trump is going to
make every attempt to undo a lot of what
President Obama has done through the EPA
during his two terms as president to
protect the environment which is really
not something that should be politicized
but it is in modern America this also
signals possibly the Donald Trump is
going to try to dismantle the
Environmental Protection Agency
altogether he talked about during the
campaign how it needs to be scaled down
drastically what it is able to do what
it does drain the swamp was the phrase
from Trump during the campaign really
seems like it's getting filled up uh
including with wastewater from fracking
and all sorts of other fossil fuels
pruitt has been a major figure in the
legal battle fighting against what
President Obama has done to protect the
climate a quote from Scott Pruett in the
National Review about a human impact on
climate change scientists continue to
disagree about the degree in extent of
global warming and it's connections to
the actions of mankind that debate
should be encouraged in classrooms in
public forums and the halls of Congress
it should not be silenced with threats
of prosecution is sent is not a crime
and of course a total straw man argument
because nobody is arguing that dissent
is a crime but this is the same type of
argument which sees some conservatives
say hey teach the 99 percent consensus
theory and the one percent consensus
theory sort of like teach evolution and
the idea that a man in the sky created
the world in six days just for balance
because it's up for debate and we're
just not totally clear on the truth at
this point Scott Pruett also just a
dishonest and sketchy dude the new york
times reported that pruitt copied the
text of an energy lobbyist letter to the
epa and pasted it on official oklahoma
state letterhead and then sent it to the
epa but to give the impression that this
was
some kind of official Oklahoma State
communication and uh we we I mean this
although we hear little bits and pieces
guys about how maybe Trump is being
pulled in a more logical direction for
example uh ivanka meeting with Al Gore
big climate change activists when you
look at the appointments there's no
indication that Trump has a sane head on
his shoulders when it comes to this and
this is now the third pic where the
choice Donald Trump put up is
philosophically opposed to the position
they're trying to run ben Carson for HUD
secretary even though he's opposed to
fair housing programs we have Betsy
DeVos for such Secretary of Education
even though she's against um public
schools must replace with vouchers yeah
it's a whole mess it really is and this
does line up rachel with what Trump said
during the presidential campaign right
that even though we had a brief period
in the middle we thought well maybe he's
gonna go in a different direction Trump
referring to human caused climate change
is a hoax perpetrated by the Chinese he
said he was going to quote cancel the
Paris accords which committed many many
nations to taking action to flight bike
climate change this is the Trump that
campaigned that's true but what I'm kind
of worried about specifically in this
case is that the clean power plan is
critical to reducing overall emissions
from I think 26 to 28 percent below the
2005 levels by 2025 and if they set a
precedent by backing away from the Paris
agreement then what if other nations
follow suit well the good news is that
as far as the clean power plan and the
war on coal there's somewhat of a limit
to what the EPA chief can do I mean they
can't just unilaterally cancel
long-standing EPA emissions regulations
a lot of those date back to the 1970 our
act but if you have an EPA chief who's
legally experienced and a real crony
right that the the types of cronies that
Donald Trump seems to love those
restrictions and regulations could be
substantially weakened they could be
delayed they could be slowly taken apart
and we've got a guy here who's a total
tool of the fossil fuel industry and
it's not just uh their if there's if
there is a silver lining here it's that
when it comes to the
all stuff and we've heard Trump go big
in favor of coal there are more reasons
beyond just regulations that coal may
not actually see a resurgence under
Donald Trump and it wouldn't have
anything to do with Trump's uh seeming
excitement about coal it's that because
natural gas is relatively inexpensive
right now there's not a big financial
situation that encourages new coal
development at this time that doesn't
mean we shouldn't worry about scott
pruett this is really really disturbing
and we're going to have to watch this
incredibly closely fortunately to some
degree many of these decisions do depend
on States now that's a double-edged
sword because we have many Republican
run state legislatures as well another
disastrous pick for the Donald Trump
administration that is incoming